What if I told you that the problem with
your writing is not that you're a bad
writer, but that you know too much? I
ran a university writing lab for 7
years, and these days I work with
nonfiction writers of all stripes, but
the problem is the same. The patterns
that experts use to think about their
subject fight with the patterns that
readers use to understand it, and that
fight has a name. It's called
interference, and it's the number one
problem of expert writing. So, in this
video, I'm going to show you why experts
write the worst, how to spot
interference patterns in your own
writing, and how to fix them so that
your ideas are as clear to your readers
as they are to you. So, what is
interference and why does it happen?
Well, quite simply, interference is the
mismatch between the patterns that you
use when you're generating the text and
the patterns that readers use whenever
they're interpreting the text. See,
that's the thing. If you're writing
valuably, then the kind of thinking that
you're doing is way too complex to sort
out in your head. It's a little bit like
Christmas lights. So, you can imagine
having a set of Christmas lights that
you pull out once a year and hang up
around the house. And you know how it
is, they're always a tangled mess. And
before you can actually put them on
display, you need to go through this
toilsome process of untangling
everything. And that's really what the
first phase of writing is. Whenever
you're writing, it's not like an essay
shape or whatever genre you're using,
it's not in that shape in your head.
It's a total mess. And you can't just go
for a walk and sort that mess out. It
doesn't happen that way. You need to, in
the first place, use the writing as an
extension of your thinking. And if you
do expert writing, then you know exactly
what I'm talking about. When you're
sitting at the keyboard and you're kind
of struggling to figure out what it even
is that you think before before you can
even think about putting it into an
essay shape for a reader. And so one way
to diagram that would be to say that
you're generating So here's the text
that you and your reader are both going
to use and you're generating it on this
horizontal axis of time where you're
simultaneously
thinking about the world and writing
about the world. And so the text is
being generated according to these
patterns where you as an expert are
thinking about the world. But the
problem with that is that readers are
using the text on a completely different
axis. They want to use the text to
understand the world. So if you think
about that expert writing process,
you're kind of moving through the text
in time. Think about it this way. You as
the writer start at the top of the text
with a question or a problem. Some
something that you don't know because
you're generating new ideas. And so you
start at the at the top of the text not
knowing. And you kind of keep on
chipping away at this draft until you
get to the bottom of the text where
you're like, "Aha, I've got it. Now it's
complete." But look at the pattern that
you've just generated. You've moved from
a state of not knowing, a state of
uncertainty, to a state of certainty or
knowing. And so now if you just hand
this off to your reader, they need to
follow your entire intellectual journey
from not knowing to knowing. Now that's
one example of a writer pattern that
doesn't serve readers. You're not making
a mistake. Everybody goes through this.
But the thing to just recognize is that
you are as you're generating this text,
you are simultaneously
thinking about the world with your own
expert patterns. We're going to talk
about those in a second, but those
patterns make it difficult for the
reader to use your text. And it's not to
just say that the patterns that writers
use and readers use are different. It's
to say that the patterns that writers
use, especially experts, which they use
to generate the text, interfere with the
patterns, the expectations that readers
use to process the text. Readers do not
want to move from uncertainty to
certainty, for example. They want the
certainty right up front. And if you
want an easy guide to the patterns that
readers use to process your text, then
you can grab my visual guide to expert
writing down below the like button. It's
four pages as a PDF, and it just gives
you a kind of road map to looking at
your essay and thinking about it the way
that readers will. These aren't like my
rules to writing. These are just the
kind of expectations that readers bring
to non-fiction writing. It's all based
on reader psychology, and so if you can
think about your text this way, then it
becomes really easy to move from that
first phase of writing, where you as the
writer are generating the text while
thinking about it, transferring that
over to the reader's draft. But how can
you spot interference in your own
writing? Well, you might think that one
way that you could find it would be to
give your text to readers and see what
they give you back. But honestly, I
think readers are the worst people to
talk to for feedback about your draft.
The reason that you don't ask readers
for feedback about your draft is for the
same reason that you don't ask a fish
how to catch a fish, or you don't ask a
woman for dating advice, if you're a
man. Ladies, do not pillory me in the
comments for this, but let me tell you
that the worst dating advice I've ever
received has always come from women. Why
is that? Well, I don't know for sure,
but what I do know for sure is that what
you say you want and what you actually
want are two different things. I had a
girl one time tell me that she wanted a
guy just like in the movie About Time.
Have you ever seen this movie? So, I I
heard this and I watched this movie and
here's the movie. It's about this dork
who just can't figure it out with women.
But, he in the movie he's got a time
machine and so every time he fumbles the
football, he can just hit undo and go
back in time and try it again. And the
entire movie is him just fumbling,
fumbling, fumbling. And girls watch that
and they melt and they say, "Oh, see,
that's what I want." Well, guys, go out
there and try it. Watch that movie, use
it like a playbook, and see how that
works for you. And honestly, it works
the same way with readers. They'll tell
you one thing, but what they actually
want is another thing. So, when your
text doesn't work with readers, here's
what they'll tell you. They'll say,
"It's unclear." They'll say, "Oh, it's
disorganized. It's a little fuzzy. It's
dense." Remember back in university when
your professor would leave you a comment
in the margins that says, "Unclear, fix
this." The problem here is that readers
don't have the vocabulary to describe
what's happening. So, honestly, like if
you were if you receive a comment like
dense or unclear or disorganized,
it that that advice is really worth
nothing. It doesn't tell you what to do.
It just tells you the way that the
reader is experiencing the text. Readers
don't have this language of saying like
your writing patterns interfere with my
reading patterns. And just understand
that these words dense, unclear,
disorganized, and those other kind of
general terms that you get in feedback
about your writing, those describe the
symptom of your writing, but they don't
describe the cause. What they're
describing, in other words, is friction.
The readers want to move through your
text. They want to process it according
to their reading patterns, but those
patterns are interfering with the
patterns that you've left on the page.
One example that I've already provided
is your own intellectual journey from
uncertainty to certainty. That's a
pattern that's going to interfere with
the readers' patterns. Readers don't
want to move from uncertainty to
certainty, they want to move from
stability to instability. And that's a
that's a different video, but it's just
one of the readers' kind of preferred
motions or journeys through a text. They
want to begin in a familiar world and
then discover that there's something
wrong with that world that they need to
understand better. That's one of the
readers' kind of expectations whenever
they come to a piece of non-fiction. So,
readers, a lot like women in the dating
market, don't have the best language for
describing what it is they want. So, if
you get negative feedback from them,
take it all with a grain of salt and try
to get to the bottom of what it is that
readers actually want. And this concept
of interference is really important for
writers to understand because when you
get that negative feedback from readers,
you don't want to wind up having to work
on the wrong thing. I'm actually working
with a writer right now who's writing a
pillar essay for a coaching program that
he's about to launch. And so, the essay
is kind of meant to introduce potential
customers and the the internet at large
to a concept that he's kind of owning in
his personal brand. And again, he's
building a
coaching educational offer on the other
end of it. But so, what he's done now,
this is a very kind of niche topic and
I've been working with him on this
draft. Now, he, like many writers
whenever they come to me, thought that
the problem would just be a matter of
line editing. So, he would bring me his
draft and I would apply some patterns to
it and turn it into a draft that works.
But, it doesn't really work that way.
Like, I really think it's important to
think about the writer's draft and the
reader's draft as two separate
documents. You have one draft where you
as the expert are thinking about the
world, you're thinking about your ideas
as you're generating the text. But, then
that text is going to make it's going to
mirror your own patterns of thinking,
which involve a lot of confusion and
kind of recursive looping in on itself
and fixing this and getting pulled down
that side trail and trying this out.
There's a lot of experimentation and
kind of iteration over, you know,
however long it takes you to generate
the text, many days at least, that goes
into it. And so, you can't really fix
that at the level of line editing. I
really think it's important, like once
you as the writer are satisfied to
walk away from that text. And that's
really hard to do because you've
invested so much of yourself into it.
Working with this writer's draft, it's a
little bit like giving directions to a
restaurant to a friend. So, imagine
you're at a restaurant, your friend's
going to come meet you. You've driven to
the restaurant from your house and now
your friend calls you and they're asking
for directions, right? So, what are you
going to do? Are you going to tell your
friend the steps that you took to arrive
at the restaurant? That's not very
helpful to your friend. Right? Your
friend is expecting you to start your
directions where you understand they are
and to give them the appropriate level
of context
to let them know how to get to the place
where you've arrived. Right? You use the
text just like the, you know, you you
arrived at the restaurant following your
own path and that path served you well.
Nothing wrong with the path that you've
taken. It's It's the steps that you
needed to take in order to arrive at
this place of clarity. But now you need
to show the reader how to get there. And
you're an expert. The reader is not
starting their journey to the restaurant
from your home. You're starting from a
completely different walk of life. You
have all these other experiences,
background knowledge, and just patterns
of thinking that are do do not suit the
reader's patterns of thinking.
And so in most cases, whenever an expert
brings me a text that they're preparing
for a specific kind of reader,
it's It's I think it's really hard for
them emotionally to accept that they
need to write a new draft. But honestly,
that draft isn't really so hard to write
once you've done all your thinking. Like
once you've arrived at a place where you
think, "Okay, I have all the pieces that
I need." Then it's actually a lot easier
to map out a trail for the reader to get
there. And the visual guide to expert
writing is basically a collection of all
the patterns that I use whenever I'm
thinking about how to prepare a reader
to go from where they are to where you
want them to be. But why is it that the
more that you know about a topic, the
worse a writer you become?
Well, on the one hand, of course, you're
the one person in the world who should
be writing about your topic because
you're an expert on it. But on the other
hand, because you're an expert, you have
compressed a lot of your knowledge into
really tight kind of conceptual packets
and heuristics that become short hands
for you, but become very dense and
difficult to manage for people who don't
know what you know. And this is
popularly known as the curse of
knowledge. But I can I don't want to use
that phrase because honestly for those
of us who are in the space of writing,
that itself becomes one of these
condensed packets of information. And I
think it it's not exactly what I'm
trying to say. The The popular
associations that we have with the curse
of knowledge, in case you're not
familiar, this is a concept that comes
from C.S. Lewis and it basically just
means that you as a writer forget what
it's like to not know what you already
know. And so the advice that follows
from this insight about the curse of
knowledge is to write simply or write at
a fifth grade level. And that's not the
takeaway that I want to make, which is
why I don't really want to use that
concept, the curse of knowledge.
Instead, I want to I want to look at
this issue afresh. To really think about
what happens when you're an expert. So
whatever it whatever it is your
whatever the field is that you're
writing it, whatever it is your your
domain of expertise,
the fact that you have expertise in that
domain means that you have gone through
a lot of learning and condensing of
information. Like when you learn
something, you only need to learn it one
time and then that becomes a kind of
landmark or a or a post in the road for
you from where you can begin the next
time you're learning. In other words,
you start thinking about your concept
using these compressed kind of chunks of
information that become like the private
machinery of your discipline. You know
these concepts really well, you take
them for granted, and there are other
people who are in your space, colleagues
like especially if you're an academic.
Now it's true of all disciplines, but
it's just easy to think about this among
academics. You know, I worked with a lot
of academics for seven years at the
writing center, and what I found is that
these people are generally writing for
each other. And so there are all these
kind of concepts and and disciplinary
norms that we take for granted whenever
we're writing to those people. But now,
whenever you're tasked with the problem
of making your research valuable to
people who are not inside your discourse
community, which might be the lay public
if you're trying to write a popular
book, but it could also be committees
who are issuing grants or funding or you
know, private investors, that kind of
thing. You need to make the value of
your research salient to them and you
forget what it's like to not know
everything that you know. So, I in one
sense, it means that yes, there's a lot
that you take for granted and so
therefore you should present these items
simply, but it's more to say that as an
expert, you you don't even realize the
amount of compression and the kind of
weird thinking patterns that you use
within your discipline. And they're ones
that you take for granted among your
peers, but
whenever you're writing for people who
are outside of that disciplinary
community, it's important to think about
what patterns are they going to be using
to interpret this? Because those are the
patterns that you need to use whenever
you're trying to reach those readers.
And so the fix here is the advice that
unfortunately, you really don't want to
hear, but it's it's the truth, which is
that you can't think of writing as being
a single act. If you're an expert, if
you are writing valuably, if you are
generating new knowledge, you're not
just regurgitating other people's ideas,
you're not doing summaries of other
people's ideas, but you're actually
trying to communicate something
valuable, which means you're solving
current problems. Right? If you are
solving open problems, if you're
answering open questions, it means you
are using your writing as an extension
of your thinking. And so by definition,
as an expert, you are going to be
generating your text along this axis,
where you are simultaneously thinking
about the world and solving these
problems while you are generating that
text. And so, therefore, you must get
used to the idea that there are there's
no fixing that draft. There's no amount
of line edits, put a comma here, put
these two things into the same
paragraph. It doesn't work. We we can't
fix these issues at the surface level,
at the formal level. It's it's a
fundamental
issue of the way that this text was
generated. It was generated to serve
your own thinking. But, if you're trying
to reach readers, if you're trying to
mobilize your expertise into something
that readers will find valuable, then we
need to generate a second text. I should
almost draw a second one over here.
Here's the one for the reader,
for the reader, and they're going to use
this to understand the world. Right,
this one is full of interference. They
can't use it. It was generated for you.
And so, after we're done this one, we
need to create a second one for the
reader that they can use. But, here's
one kind of concrete tip that you can
use whenever you are trying to fix these
problems of interference. So, of course,
grab that PDF, but then one thing you'll
notice in it is
>> at every level of resolution throughout
the text. So, we see that index and
discussion pattern at the level of the
entire text, where you have your
introduction and then the body, but then
when you zoom into the parts of the
body, you see that there's the index and
discussion here.
And the tip is to do what's called the
skim test. And so, once you've kind of
laid out your ideas into this index
discussion pattern, what you can do is
highlight just the index positions and
see whether those create a kind of
storyboard for the major steps or
rhetorical moves that you want the
reader to move through because the index
is supposed to preview the major piece
of information in the entire unit of
discourse. And so, the way that you can
test that as a kind of diagnostic is to
is to see whether just the index
positions tell a coherent story. And so,
that skim test amounts to what's known
as a reverse outline. Right, you don't
really want to
Like, of course, a common piece of
advice is to create an outline for your
text, but the problem with that is that
if you create the outline first, then
you it it's hard to fit especially
expert patterns. Like,
you're As an expert, you're not just
writing listicles. Right, you're not
writing top five things. And so, it's
hard to like generate an outline first
and then fill it in because again,
you're using writing as an extension of
your thinking. So, one idea comes and
then you kind of expand it and and sort
of exploring it and then that might take
you down a little, you know, a little
tributary and you go down that path and
right, so it it doesn't really work so
well if you're trying to generate an
outline first. So, what I recommend
instead is use your writing in whatever
patterns it occurs to you spontaneously.
Like, let your mind wander while you're
writing. Absolutely do not think about
reading patterns while you're generating
your text. But then, as you start to
adapt the the weird thing that you've
developed that served your own thinking,
when you start adapting that for
readers, you do need to make sure that
there's a kind of coherent structure to
it all. And so, the way that you can do
that is with this reverse outline.
Right? You can look at your text and
then draw lines demarcating the
different sections. And then, within
those sections, draw a line that
demarcates what's known as the index.
And then, look only at those indexes and
see whether they tell a coherent story.
And if, as you're generating this
reverse outline, you cannot really label
a part, well, it's probably still a
tangled knot of Christmas lights or it's
just fluff. Right? Ideally, these
indexes throughout the piece are going
to mark the major turns in your reader's
journey. If you go back to the metaphor
about the reader finding their way to
the restaurant. Right? These index
positions should be like the major turns
that they're going to take on the way to
the destination. But you can't really
map out the reader's route if you don't
know what patterns they'll use to get
there. So, be sure to watch this video
next because it's going to show you the
five reading patterns that, if you
follow them, is going to make your
writing so much better from the reader's
perspective. So, be sure to go check it
out.